bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filcho comme chaque semaine nous
revenons sur l'actualité économique de
la semaine voici les grandes lignes de
l'émission première visite autour de la
Nouvelle-France industrielle pour Arnaud
Montebourg le ministre du redressement
productif était lundi au siège de
cassidian à hencour
800 postes à pourvoir dans le secteur de
la vente l'outlet de luxe one nation
Paris organisé cette semaine un job
dating la marque château de Versailles
continue son expansion après sa gamme
d'épisteré fil lancé la semaine dernière
elle coédite une bande dessinée le
château de versaill un concept vendeur
c'est notre dossier de la semaine et
puis nous célébrons cette semaine la
semaine européenne de la mobilité
l'occasion de discuter des moyens de
faciliter les transports domicile
travail des salariés nous en discuterons
avec notre invité maïis florier bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes la référente des
plans de déplacement interentreprise de
la communauté d'agglomération de c-qutin
en Yveline nous discuterons du coup de
ce qui est mis en place localement à
tout à l'heure on passe maintenant à
l'actualité économique de la
semaine avoir annoncé 34 plans de
reconquête industrielle la semaine
dernière Arnaud Montebourg s'est rendit
au siège de cassidian à encour deux
marchés ont été évoqués la cybersécurité
et le développement du réseau 4G des
images de Jonathan
villman lundi le ministre du
redressement productif s'est rendu au
siège de cassidian à hlencour objectif
affiché rendre concret le lancement des
34 plans de reconquête industrielle
annoncé la semaine dernière dans cette
filiale de ads on mise notamment sur le
numérique l'un des quatre piliers de la
nouvelle mesure accompagné de Benoît
amont et de fleur pèin il a rencontré
des salariés du groupe dont ses
ingénieurs en recherche et développement
défendez bien la France je crois que
vous le faites bien déjàue merci
beaucoup protéger la France ou plutôt
son économie et ses emplois via
l'innovation voilà l'enjeu cassidian
cherche notamment à concurrencer les
entreprises étrangères dans les secteurs
de la communication sécurisée et de la
cybersécuritéil vous PLT nous pouvons
considérer que ce défendre est une
activité de souveraineté c'est aussi une
activité de nature économieque
industrielle et créatrice d'emploi c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle nous avons
décider d'en faire un des 34 plans
industriel présenté à l'égisée sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
le plan numéro 33 s'appelle
cyberc un partenariat public privé a été
mis en place avec à la clé des
investissements notamment dans la
recherche et une évolution de la
législation dans le numérique on évoque
le nombre de 150000 emplois créés ou
sauvés et plus de 15 milliards d'euros
de valeur ajouté généré nous avons un un
écosystème et un réseau d'acteurs qui
sont extrêmement performants qui
d'ailleurs exporte beaucoup de leur
chiffre d'affaires à l'étranger et nous
allons essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils
coopèrent davantage pour pouvoir
entraîner à la fois tout un tissu de PME
et TPE innovant dans leur dans leur
sillage et puis les aider à se
constituer vraiment en groupe de taille
mondiale encore aujourd'hui une
entreprise met en moyenne 371 jours
avant de repérer une cyberataque bien
trop long du côté de la communication
sécurisée cette fois cassidan offre un
réseau 4G disponible partout sans risque
de saturation mais elle nécessite une
fréquence de 400 méz pour se développer
son alliance avec l'État est primordiale
c'estétat qui est le dépositaire des
fréquences et le choix des fréquences
que fera la France dans le domaine des
télécommunations sécurisé sera un modèle
pour rest de l'Europe c'est absolument
fondamental j' discuté avec la ministre
fleurin c'est quelque chose qu'on doit
faire dans les 12 prochains mois c'est
là jeu va se jouer peut-être de quoi
rivaliser avec les États-Unis les plans
d'action dans le secteur numérique
prévoi également de plancher sur l'
éducation l'hôpital numérique ou encore
les objets connectés alors un absent
lors de la visite d'Arnaud monbour en
cours le président de la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des Yvelines
nous avons donc demander à Gérard
bachelier ce qu'il aurait eu envie de
dire au ministre on écoute sa réponse on
a plein de choses à dire au ministre et
en particulier au ministre donc qui
s'occupe de l'industrie actuellement
Arnaud
mandbourg on a besoin surtout que les
chambres de commerces soient appuyer
parce que on a l'impression que les
chambres de commerce n'ont pas l'appui
actuellement an du gouvernement pour le
développement de l'économie sur leur
territoire nous sommes des structures
importantes pour notre territoire il
faut que les chambres de commerces
puissent avoir les moyens de d'offrir
des services et on n'est pas toujours
soutenu je pense par le monde politique
on a besoin du soutien des politiques
pour passer nos messages on a
besoin des
éléments d'un soutien budgétaire aussi
puisque actuellement on se pose des
questions sur les budgets des chambres
de commerce et l'évolution des des
budgets des chambres de commerce on a
besoin d'un budget important pour offrir
des services à nos entreprises coaction
est un réseau d'entreprise mais pas
n'importe lequel il regroupe des
président d'association d'entreprise ce
qui représente 600 sociétés adhérentes
des grands groupes comme des PME une
fois par an une réunion est organisé
elle vient de se dérouler à Montini le
Bretonneux des images de Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude donc combien de recettes de
confitures différentes propose
entreprise és confiture 200 400 ou 600
une
se00000000 on dit 40000 ici vous dites
600 ici vous dit00 400 la répon c'est
600 il joue autour du même table un quiz
sur les entreprises ivelinoises autour
du thème du bon goût une ambiance détaée
pourant c'est très sérieux eux sont chef
d'entreprise et tous membres du réseau
coaction un réseau créé en 2008 par la
Chambre de commerce pour mettre en
relation les présidents d'association
d'entreprises coaction ce sont
aujourd'hui plus de 600 entreprises
adhérentes c'est quand même un beau
réseau et qui nous permet à la Chambre
de commerce d'avoir une relation
privilégiée un effet de levier un relais
puisque les associations sont pour nous
un relais vis-à-vis des entreprises
c'est tout type de de taille
d'entreprise dans tous les domaines donc
l'industrie le
service le commerce peut-être un peu
moins mais surtout industrie et services
et et donc ça permet d'avoir aussi des
relations entre PME TPE et grandes
entreprises et c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut développer sur notre territoire
parmi les associations partenaires le
réseau Delta ski sur saintquenttin en
yeline un réseau puissant de 40
entreprises qui totalise 60 % des
salariés du territoire il est toujours
important de pouvoir travailler en
réseau de bénéficier de l'expérience des
autres d'échanger sur nos bonnes
pratiques ça permet d'être un acteur et
d'avoir une voix qui pter pour
l'ensemble de ces entreprises au niveau
de
l'agglomération de la région voire même
de de l'État ça nous permet à nous de
nous faire entendre mais ça permet aussi
aux administrations aux politiques
d'avoir un seul interlocuteur pour
toucher un grand nombre de salariés un
grand nombre d'entreprises la CCI des
Yvelines dispose également d'autres
outils de partenariat tels que le réseau
plateau là ce sont des cadres de grandes
entreprises qui viennent apporter leur
expérience aux dirigeants de
PMO on se rend maintenant aux clés
sousbois un job deting était organisé
cette semaine les recruteurs des
enseignes du futur outlet de luxe one
nation Paris des images des Lady one
l'outlet de luxe one nation Paris
ouvrira ses portes au clés sous-bois le
20 novembre les travaux sont encore en
cours mais les 112 magasins se préparent
déjà en constituant leurs équipes ici on
recherche des conseillers de vente et
des responsables de magasins dans qu 80
% des cas de préférence multilingue pour
faire face à une clientèle à 40 %
étrangère recruteur enchaîne les
rendez-vous scrute les CV un job dating
pour recruter local organisé cette
semaine pour le coup c'est vachement
porteur parce que bon quand on est pas
du tout de la région on sait pas par où
commencer pour recruter dans le coin
donc c'est pas mal les profils ont été
étudiés en amont notamment par Pôle
emploi mais pour de nombreuses enseignes
il ne s'agit ici que d'une présélection
avant de nouveaux entretiens voir un
essai en magasin ce concept atypique ne
désarçonne pas pour autant les
postulants j'ai été reçu par des gens
très agréables très charmant qui m'ont
très très bien renseigné très bien
accueilli surtout et puis voilà quoi
j'espère que ça aboutira 800 postes sont
à pourvoir et ce chiffre pourrait
augmenter de nouvelles enseignes
devraient rejoindre l'outlet d'ici la
fin de l'année et une nouvelle enseigne
a déjà annoncer sa venue Armani elle
disposera d'un espace de 600 m car on
passe maintenant à l'entretien
c'est la Semaine européenne de la
mobilité et mais florier notre invité a
été beaucoup occupé vous êtes allé à la
rencontre des salariés d'entreprise du
secteur pour discuter donc des modes de
transport notamment domicile travail
donc on va quand même vous présenter
vous êtes la référente des plans de
déplacement interentreprise à la
communauté d'agglomération de 5quentin
en Yveline alors tout simplement un
un plan de déplacement interentreprise
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement
alors un P en fait c'est c'est un
travail qu'on mène avec les entreprises
avec des référents dans les entreprises
pour essayer d'améliorer toutes les
conditions de transport d'accessibilité
aux entreprises donc que ce soit que les
salariés viennent en bus à pied en vélo
en voiture on essaie d'améliorer les
conditions d'accès vous coordonnerz et
vous aideer à mettre en place les
mesures pour les entreprises voilà donc
à ce propos on a cherché à savoir ce qui
était fait dans une entreprise
spécifique nous nous sommes rendus au
Technocentre Renault je vous propose de
regarder ce tour d'horizon des
différentes mesures mises en place un
sujet réalisé avec Jonathan
villman depuis 2008 Renault a mis en
place un plan de déplacement
d'entreprise en clair des mesures pour
optimiser les déplacements liés aux
activités professionnelles et limiter la
pollution en tant que défenseur de la
voiture électrique le constructeur
automobile a bien entendu mise à
disposition de ses salariés des places
munies de bornes électrique mais le
principal levier reste les transports en
commun une gare routière a été créée sur
le site du Technocentre et des dcerve
ces 15 hectares actuellement bien on a
précisément mais cela bouge hein dans il
y a 6 mois c'était pas la même chose et
peut-être dans un an ce sera différent
on a 14 lignes de bus qui dcervent le
Technocentre Renault dans les nouveautés
par exemple la ligne 9106 dessert Massis
ORL des aménagements obtenus moyenne en
finance auprès du stifff et de
l'agglomération résultat 14 % des
salariés utilisent les transports en
commun concernant le covoiturage des
plateformes test ont été créées sans
succès mais une collaboration avec le
site dédié W up est en réflexion autre
moyen de limiter les déplacement en
voiture le télétravail un accord a
permis de se mettre en télétravail un
jour par semaine hein et là tout de
suite on a augmenté de 30- 35 % le
nombre de télétravailleurs du travail à
domicile et de fait moins de déplacement
seul point noir du constructeur les
modes doux comme le vélo et la marche à
pied ne connaissent qu'un faible succès
alors que 1500 collaborateur habit à
moins de 5 km du site
voà et concernant ces mesures nous
n'avons par contre pas pu obtenir
d'informations concernant le budget
dédié je pense que c'est la même chose
on n pas forcément d'information
là-dessus au niveau de la communauté
d'agéation euh sur le budget dédié on
sait les améliorations qu'on fait par
exemple quand on améliore l'offrebus le
nombre de kilomètres qu'on met en plus
ou des choses comme ça les aménagements
cyclable mais après ça fait partie de de
la viille de la communauté
d'agglomération parce qu'on passe aussi
du temps euh à à travailler avec les
entreprises donc ça c'est du du budget
temps humain euh donc si on le retrouve
dans les budgets de la la casqui après
je l'ai pas exactement d'accord donc on
l'a vu le principal enjeu bah c'est les
transports en commun euh votre activité
c'est également donc du coup de de
faciliter les transports via les bus euh
les bus parce que c'est un transport de
masse ça concerne 20 % des salariés en
fait en général qui viennent sur les
sites euh après on essaie d'améliorer
aussi les autres alternatives à la
voiture que sont le vélo donc dans ce
cas-là c'est d'essayer de faire des
pcyclables quand les entre souhait sont
en faveur du vélo pour venir à
l'entreprise on se pose des questions
sur les cheminements piéton également
donc voilà c'est l'ensemble des modes de
transport pour arriver aux entreprises
et puis il y a le coiturage pour mieux
utiliser la voiture alors on va les
prendre un à un on commence par les bus
je crois qu'il y a eu des améliorations
notamment sur la ligne 15 alors il y a
eu des améliorations sur la ligne 15
pour aller à la clé Saint-Pierre mais en
fait c'est depuis 2008 qu'on met en
place les plans de déplacement
interentreprise donc il y a eu des
améliorations sur les lignes qui vont à
la clé Saint-Pierre la 463 la 475 il y a
eu des améliorations sur les liges qui
vont vers le secteur des SAES sangliers
la 468 il y a eu des améliorations sur
les lignes qui vont au Technocentre avec
création de de ligne 460 et 466 et
récemment on s'est attaqué à la zone
d'activité de trappel en cours où là on
a créé une ligne pour mieux desservir
les salariés qui s'appelle la C 130 donc
effectivement sur tous les secteurs il y
a des améliorations quand on sait que ça
ça répond vraiment au besoins des
salariés voilà et auudelà des lignes
vous pouvez également par exemple
déplacer des arrêts pour faciliter les
oui améliorer les transports collectifs
c'est pas juste faire des renforts
d'offres c'est aussi des fois des
solutions toutes simples où euh quand on
connaît pas l'organisation d'une
entreprise des fois on a mis des arrêts
devant l'entrée qui était pas la plus
utilisée par les salariés ou en tout cas
qui permet peut-re pas de faire les
chemins les plus court dans l'entreprise
et donc on modifie les arrêts pour que
ce soit le plus court le plus simple
possible pour les salariés l'objectif je
crois c'est d'arriver à un taux
d'utilisation des transport en commun de
20 % 2020 contre 15 aujourd'huiable
alors euh il est plutôt 17 18 % le taux
du l'utilisation des des transports
collectifs dans les entreprises 15 %
pour les
habitants donc effectivement on essaie
d'aller vers un 20 % en transport
collectif réalisable ou pas il est
réalisable à condition aussi donc au
niveau local on améliore beaucoup
l'offre de bus l'offre locale par contre
il est vrai qu'il faudrait aussi
améliorer l'offre ferroviaire pour
lequel beaucoup de salariés viennent par
exemple de Paris donc il y a un travail
aussi à faire sur l'offre ferroviaire
qui dépend du STIF alors chez Renault il
n nous ont expliqué que le coiture
ourage poser problème les gens sont
intéressés mais ça a du mal de se mettre
en place alors je sais que la communauté
d'agglomération met en a mis en place un
site internet dédié alors est-ce qu'il
fonctionne est-ce qu'il y a des quaks
alors c'est un site qui fonctionne en
fait c'est un site où on met en relation
les gens on a créé des des des parties
dédiées pour les entreprises si les
salariés veulent d'abord se reconnaître
entre eux parce que ça les encourage à
faire du
covoiturage ce qui se passe après c'est
que effectivement dans dans nos modes de
vie actuel les gens ont un peu du mal
avec le covatural parce que ça répond
pas au au besoin de faire plein de
courses après son travail ses propres
contraintes euh le crédau après c'est
dire on peut peut-être essayer de faire
du covoiturage pour une ou deux journées
dans la semaine euh parce qu'il y a
toujours une ou deux journées où on a
moins de contraintte que les autres donc
sur ces créneaux-là c'est sûrement
faisable de faire un peu plus de
covoiturage et peut-être une solution
avec le la nouvelle société qui s'est
créée WAZ up peut-être peut-être euh
pourquoi pas parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui jusqu'à présent on
travaillait sur des plateformes internet
de citurage où les gens euh regarder les
annonces des uns et des autres
aujourd'hui ce qui est en train de se
développer c'est du covoiturage
dynamique c'està dire que en temps réel
sur un smartphone on sait qu' y a
quelqu'un qui veut arriver qui va partir
dans 15 minutes avec du covoiturage donc
effectivement c'est peut-être une
solution pour les prochaines années à
envisager alors au niveau du vélo donc
il y a deux choses il y a l'achat groupé
de de vélo assistance électrique donc ça
s'est mis en place plutôt par les
entreprises l'agglomération oui une aide
financière non mais on par contre un
aide pour trouver les les bons
interlocuteurs et les bons prix au
niveau des des vendeurs de vélo parce
que c'est notre métier c'est les
transports c'est pas le métier des
directeurs d'établissement par exemple
ouais ce qui ce qui est mis également en
place c'est des aménagements cyclables
donc là-dessus il y a eu des des
améliorations il y a des améliorations
notamment vers le secteur des sa
sangliers parce qu'on sait que les
entreprises étaient favorables au vélo
et donc on a essayé de de faire des
aménagements dans ce secteur alors votre
service donc était cette semaine sur le
terrain à la rencontre des salariés nous
nous sommes allés faire un tour du du
côté d'orange où vous aviez également
une petite animation des petits stands
et nous sommes tombés sur un salarié qui
habite à FONTEN fleur et qui a une
question à vous poser donc je propose de
l'écouter je me pose des questions sur
les interconnexions entre les les
réseaux les réseaux entre les
différentes communautés de commune parce
que là on voit bien ce qui a été fait
sur communauté de commune ville nouvelle
mais moi j'appartiens une autre
communauté de commune qui est celle de
versaill grand parc donc je connaître
les interconnexions au niveau des
réseaux entre ces deux inter
intercommunauté de commune alors
justement est-ce qu' y a des passerelles
alors effectivement les agglomérations
travaillent ensemble on n'est pas sur
des îles perdues au milieu de l'océan et
on a consciance de ses besoins de
déplacement vers les autres territoires
l'exemple ça va être bah la dernière
pyclab qu'on a fait entre saint-cir et
aiguille en cour au niveau du
rond-point des droits de l'homme des
droits de l'homme qui permet de faire la
connexion qui manquait jusqu'à présent
donc effectivement on pense que on
améliore le réseau cyclable sur
l'agglomération et on n'oublie pas les
connexions vers les autres territoires
très bien bon il entendra peut-être
votre réponse ça le rassurera peut-être
lui en tout cas venait en en voiture
parce que il trouvait le le réseau un
peu trop compliqué on verra si c'est
amélioré dans les années à venir M
fluier merci beaucoup d'être
d'êtreevenue sur ce plateau merci à vous
on passe maintenant au dossier de la
semaine
ou pas petit petit problème technique
euh donc on va le le lancer quand même
on va essayer cette cette semaine une
nouvelle BD est sortie sur la la vie
château à Versailles la semaine dernière
le château lancaé son épisserie fine
alors est-ce qu' un business secré
autour de de l'image du du château
réponse avec le dossier de la semaine un
sujet réalisé avec Patrick Jacques de
disxmud Elodie moine et Anthony rche le
château de Versailles attire chaque
année plus de 6 millions de visiteurs
cet été le nombre de touristes a encore
augmenté de 5 % par rapport à l'été
dernier et pourtant depuis 2011 le
château utilise de plus en plus son
image de marque pour s'ouvrir à d'autres
marchés une stratégie de développement
commercial entamée en 2011 pour créer de
nouvelles rentrées d'argent outre les
produits floqués en tout genre du
parapluie à la bougie Marie-Antoinette
le château de Versailles vend dorénavant
des licences de marque l'année dernière
il prêtait son nom à un jeu à gratter
pour la Française des jeux la marque
château de Versailles un nouveau
business la semaine dernière Catherine
péard la directrice du chat lancer une
gamme de produits d'épicerie fine
labellisé château de Versailles au menu
fois gras confiture au surau sauvage ou
encore soupe de courge au curry une
gamme créée par une société girondine
aux légumes oubliés le projet est né à
la demande de Versailles il y a une
volonté de de rechercher un partenariat
de leur part moi j'ai répondu à un appel
d'offre et ça s'est mis en place à
partir du de l'automne derrière les
produits proposés s'inspirent des fruits
et légumes appréciés au temps des rois
et reennes selon la direction du château
de Versailles le pourcentage sur les
recettes est très faible l'enjeu ne se
veut pas économique notre socle c'est ce
château c'est l'histoire de versaill et
et simplement C ces produits sont un
nouvel élément d'une diplomatie puisque
le mot est à la mode aujourd'hui d'une
diplomatie culturelle qui ne passe pas
seulement par les livres qui passe
encore une fois par d'autres vecteurs et
la gastronomie en éteint la contribution
de ces produits c'est aussi travailler
pour Versailles parce que c'est aussi
nous aider à faire connaître Versailles
mais aussi à a restaurer Versailles
remeubler Versailles et montrer
Versailles se développer pour mieux
rayonner et grâce à la gastronomie
pourquoi pas à l'international ces
produits sont disponibles en ligne au
château dans de grandes enseignes
versaillaises ou parisiennes comme le
bon marché et lafillette gourmet mais
également à l'étranger meugè Monaco
Andor ou encore shangï où un bureau
dédié vient d'être ouvert bien plus près
de chez nous la ferme de Gal partenaire
du Château propose déjà la collection un
état été installé la semaine dernière
dans le magasin la marque aux légumes
oubliés était déjà présente mais le
directeur confirme que cette association
à la marque château de Versailles va
élargir la clientèle on va avoir deux
types de public qui vont être intéressés
par ce produit on a un public qui est en
recherche de bons produits de produits
traditionnels de bonnes recettes
éventuellement même de l'utilisation des
légumes oubliés donc là on est sur un
public local terroir et on va avoir un
deuxième type de public c'est la
clientèle étrangère aujourd'hui le
château de versaill est un des monuments
les plus visités au monde il y a
beaucoup d'étrangers qui viennent ici au
magasin de la ferme de Gal et qui seront
contents pour ramener les souvenirs pour
découvrir des produits typiques français
de découvrir ces produits à la marche
châau de Versailles un souvenir un
produit de qualité chacun s'y
retrouve autre développement commerciale
la bande dessinée depuis l'année
dernière le château de Versailles
coédite avec les éditions glena un
triptique sur le château cette semaine
éditeur scénariste et dessinateur
présentai le deuxè tome l'ombre de
Marie-Antoinette où ça au château bien
sûr ou plus exactement dans la
dépendance de campagne de Louis XV le
Petit Trianon dans cette bande dessinée
on suit les aventures d'un jeune
Américain propulsé au 18e siècle en
pleine révolution française un mélange
des genres entre récit historique et
science-fiction jeanul bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le directeur général des
éditions glena vous prés prentter
aujourd'hui ce deuxè tome sur le thème
du château de Versailles qui a pris
l'initiative c'est finalement à partir
de l'histoire que vous êtes dit B
pourquoi pas cette alliance où
finalement l'histoire é adaptée comment
ça s'est passé un nous avons un service
de développement qui qui va chercher des
projets aussi et des partenariats donc
nous avons rencontré les gens du château
de Versailles qui très vite se sont
avérés très intéressés par par ce projet
et justement le côté un petit peu
novateur de ce qu'on leur proposé c'est
pas c'est-à-dire de ne pas faire de la
bande dessinée purement historique mais
d'ouvrir à des univers comme la S
fiction qui est présente dans les deux
thèmes puisqu'on va voyager dans le
temps on parle du futur là on revient
vers le passé grâce à un effet de magie
on pénètre à l'intérieur d'un tableau et
donc ça ça les intéressait c'était de
sortir du cadre habituel de leur
publication et on a eu plusieurs séances
de travail avec le scénariste de la
monde
dessinée pour justement trouver quelque
chose qui leur correspondre qui
correspondent à leurs attentes et puis
qu'on pouvait mettre à leur disposition
quoi grâce à nos auteurs conservateur a
vu et revu scénarios et dessins pour
coller parfaitement au fait et au décor
de l'époque on se glisse dans les
petites failles que l'histoire a oublié
et on raconte une histoire parallèle
c'est le grand intérêt de de ces
paradoxes mais chaque événement chaque
lieu sont vrais le pavillon dans lequel
on se trouve justement sur le tome 1 il
m'est arrivé de refaire justement les
les carreaux de fenêtres parce qu'à
l'époque il y en avait deux fois plus
donc ça n'a pas échappé aux yeux du
conservateur
avec ce projet l'objectif du château de
Versailles est clair pouvoir voyager
dans le temps et et voyager ici à
travers la bande desiné c'est une autre
façon de connaître Versailles c'est pour
certains lecteurs une autre façon de
s'en approcher et peut-être de devenir
demain les visiteurs de Versailles nos
visiteurs un moyen original de grossir
la clientèle il faut dire que ce site
touristique arrive difficilement à
l'équilibre les ventes de produits et
prestations de services la billetterie
par exemple exemple n'ont rapporté que
42 millions et demi d'euros en 2011 soit
moins de la moitié des frais de
fonctionnement alors tous les moyens
sont bons non se défend la direction
tous les projets mis en œuvre conservent
la culture du lieu et c'est maintenant
l'heure de
l'agenda une date à retenir le 25
septembre le Club des Entrepreneurs de
la plaine de Versailles se réunit à
sancir cadre auto-entrepreneur
dirigeants ou encore commerçants se
réunissent ils recevront la CGPME et des
spécialistes du coworking c'est la fin
de ce filco merci d'avoir été avec nous
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un prochain numéro à
bientôt